crazy
uh
all right you have to think outside your
box right it's not easy
so you don't come back and turn
get the leverage point under your weight
then trade sides
so that the left side becomes the front
side
you drop that shoulder straight down to
the ground
so this hand
here then back
with the shoulder into the ground turn
the arm
drop your leg onto that upper arm
so
so don't use your knee
to bring them down you want the
platform stabilized so boom
down she is she's down that's the idea
you guys understand that difference so i
have redundant
overlapping systems of control so the
first
one is here
okay she's down then i'm going to
replace the
hand on the elbow
that's where i go to the other one don't
kneel them down okay try it again okay
so
first move
just hit
so energy's coming in boom moving out of
the way off to the side just like
if she's punching me to my face right
boom are you carrying it it's the same
thing
off to the side boom
boom okay all right
i take my weight and i come onto the
back leg you see that
oh not here
okay shifting onto the back leg
has the absorption you see that so if i
stay here
that's not absorbing okay so i time it
and it has me clearing the line see i
was here
and now i'm over here you guys
understand okay
so boom
see i'm beginning
so when i step back i don't go step
here
start to turn
because if i step straight back i have a
retreating element
you see the difference
what i'm going to do is turn
down
did i see my orientation to her body
i'm not looking this way across her
shoulder
down then when she's down
i turn the arm
okay it's going to hurt
oh
you're below the elbow
you guys are this
you see that you see it that movement
oh okay affected by what i'm doing
hi okay you guys are here
right in his shoulder
you have to take the slack out of the
arm here there's nothing
you just give him his base with his hand
down
so you take the slack out
you see once the slack is out then you
start
put your wig on
but it's very very small flat
lose the arc
when you arm hurt you turn
slide out boom
you